ينضم الينا من داخل مقبره نور شمس في
طولكرم مراسل الجزيره حسان مسعود اذا حسان
نتابع معك في هذه الاثناء تشييع الشهداء
الذين سقطوا في طول كرم تحديدا في مخيم
نور شمس لو تطلعنا على الاجواء من
حولك تماما غنوه الفلسطينيون هنا في مخيم
نور شمس كما في مدينه طولكرم وكذلك من
مخيم طولكرم اتوا الى هذه المقبره في هذه
الاثناء
لوداع خمسه من الشهداء الذين قضوا في اخر
اقتحام شهده مخيم نور شمس خلال الليله
الفائته والذي استمر ل 11 ساعه هذا
الاجتياح الكبير الذي قامت به قوات
الاحتلال معززه بعدد كبير من الاليات التي
استقدمت الى المخيم وعدد من الجرافات
الثقيله ايضا التي قامت بتخريب وتجريف
الطرقات والمباني في المخيم ادى الى
استشهاد الشبان الخمسه ومن بينهم مقاومون
تصدوا لهذا الاقتحام عبر اطلاق النار
وكذلك عبر تفجير عبوات ادت الى اعطاب احدى
اليات قوات الاحتلال من طراز نمر التي
تحمل تسعه من جنود الاحتلال عاده اقتحام
واسع استخدم
فيه عدد من الجنود القناصه وكذلك الاليات
في اقتحام مخيم نور شمس لكن المقاومه
الكبيره لهذا الاقتحام ادت الى استخدام
قوات الاحتلال لمسيرات لقصف الشبان
الفلسطينيين في داخل المخيم قبل ان تتمكن
من الدخول اليه وهو ما ادى الى استشهاد
الشبان الخمسه والذين يتم وداعهم في هذه
اللحظات هنا في داخل مقبره مخيم نور شمس
هذا المخيم الذي كان قد شهد عده اقتحامات
خلال الايام الماضيه خلال الفتره التي
تشهد اقتحامات واسعه في الضفه الغربيه
بشكل مكثف و وبشكل يومي منذ السابع من
اكتوبر وحتى هذه اللحظات قوات الاحتلال لم
تتوقف عن الاقتحام المتواصل لمخيمات
ومحافظات الضفه الغربيه المختلفه من اقصى
شمالها في جنين في طولكرم في نابلس الى
اقصى جنوبها في الخليج مرورا بمحافظه رام
الله والبي وقلق وبيت لحم وكل هذه
المحافظات وبالاضافه طبعا الى طوباس تشهد
بشكل يومي اقتحامه متواصله وتؤدي في كل
مره الى هذا المشهد الى مشهد وداع الشهداء
بالاضافه ايضا
ال مراسل الجزيره من طول كرم هذه التغطيه
مستمره يستكملها معكم الزميل عبد السلام